one way you can narrow down the topics
for interview is by looking at the job
descriptions for each position you apply
to if C++ is a primary language listed
you'll be best served by practicing in
this if not lean toward the language of
the companies you are most interested in
make sure if you list a programming
language on your resume you're prepared
to answer a question with it
companies want to measure your
proficiency in what you've listed also
if there's a responsibility or minimum
requirement listed for the job expect
that to be a potential area of
questioning in the interview before your
interview you should also consider
asking your recruiter who you will
interview with and what the topics of
the interview will be that might vastly
narrow down what you need to prepare for
let's walk through a recent job posting
for a machine learning and computer
vision engineer to see what we can
gather to start most companies put some
information at the top about what the
company and team does make sure you know
this information and do some research on
your own as well you'll definitely get
asked why you're interested in this
company and often get asked on what you
know about what the company does you
want to be able to give an answer that
goes deeper than just common knowledge
about the company this may not have been
apparent from the job title loan but
this role actually relates to their
mapping and localization team as well
but an applying machine learning and
computer vision toward it so you'll want
to prepare for the primary roles topics
the localization and mapping will also
likely be an area of this interview now
that we are - the responsibilities
section we can tell SLAM computer vision
and machine learning are part of the
normal responsibilities of their role it
also mentioned the staying current with
the latest research Vezina conferences
etc which means you'll either be asked
about some recent papers you've read or
conferences you've attended alternately
you should bring these up in your
interview if you feel you stand out in
this area the last two responsibilities
in deploying production code and working
with international teams will likely be
a question of explaining a time you've
done so if applicable showing why you
are a great teammate is important for
any role
let's move to experience and skills if
you made it past a phone screen and onto
a technical interview it typically means
you have at least met the minimum
experience and skills they want to see
for the position we can still utilize
this for some predictions of questions
you might be asked for this role again
we see a mention of recent research so
be prepared to talk about anything
you've read lately in the area next a
key item here it's listing out various
deep learning and machine learning
algorithms you'll likely be asked to
code something using one of these
libraries next up it mentions
mathematical skills so you may be asked
to solve a fairly complex mathematical
problem this may be fairly far-reaching
but is likely related to a problem in
machine learning or mapping based on
what we've seen so far lastly it
mentions algorithms and C++ which is
another reminder for you that this
autonomous systems interview course is
just one piece of the puzzle here many
jobs also have a nice-to-have
or ways to stand out section here we see
mapping geometry robotics and autonomous
driving technology if you've taken one
of our nano degree programs and
autonomous systems you have experience
in each of these make sure to both
highlight these on your resume and to
bring them up in your interview even if
you aren't specifically asked directly
about them